tonight we take a closer look at what
appears to many viewers
to be a seismic and long-term shift
left on the part of the mainstream media
so is it happening
and if so what are the reasons and the
ramifications
here's fox news media analyst and host
of fox's media buzz
howard kurtz the media have been accused
for decades of liberal bias
by richard nixon the press
is by george h.w
bush not so much by barack obama the
feeling most people get when they hear
barack obama's speech my i felt this
thrill going up my leg and by donald
trump
who hit back hard these are just
dishonest
terrible people i'm telling you that
fake fake
disgusting news but have four years of
increasingly hostile coverage of trump
made the press more reflexively
anti-republican now that joe biden
is president it's a difficult question
because biden has a less confrontational
style
but many reporters seem to admire him
the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man when the new york post broke the
story of hunter biden's incriminating
laptop
not only did twitter censor the story
and later apologize
it was incredible interference and
manipulation of the right to vote in the
right to be heard
but npr's managing editor dismissed it
saying we don't want to waste our time
on stories that are not really stories
the laptop's contents were confirmed
but now that the president's son is out
with a book on his drug addiction
many in the media are sympathetic that
hunter biden clip
it is really it's a gut punch i mean
this really humanizes something that
former president trump and the right
tried to exploit the press has been
somewhat tougher on the president
after an initially slow start over the
crisis of migrant children at the border
was it a mistake not to anticipate this
surge and the barring of journalists
from overcrowded facilities blocking
access to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president but some are still deflecting
blame from biden's policies
and pointing at his predecessor the
difference here is that a lot of these
children are
part of a problem that the biden
administration inherited from the trump
administration
now that biden is pushing his second
straight two trillion dollar bill on
infrastructure and more
the coverage has been largely
sympathetic one cnn news headline
declaring
with an eye on history biden moves on
big
bold and progressive infrastructure
packages
when new york governor andrew cuomo
lionized by the press early in the
pandemic
was found to have withheld information
on nursing home deaths
the media were slow to pursue it and
when a former aide accused him of sexual
harassment which cuomo denies
the network evening newscast ignored it
and cnn ran two
very brief items but it was the new york
times that tracked down cuomo's second
accuser charlotte bennett
and cbs that put her on the air do you
believe that he was propositioning you
yes we shouldn't kid ourselves a lot of
consumers of political press
they find the outlets that basically
inform a lot of their views
60 minutes drew widespread criticism for
a story trying to link a vaccine
contract ordered by florida governor ron
desantis
to a political donation the criticism is
that it's pay to play governor
it's wrong it's a fake narrative i just
disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts but
the cbs program refused to air most of
the governor's response
or to admit the piece was one-sided it
seems clear
joe biden is getting an easy ride so far
that the media downplayed the cuomo
scandals until they were too big to
ignore
while being much rougher on such gop
leaders as florida's ron desantis
there are important exceptions of course
but that helps explain why
three months after trump left office
republican mistrust of the media
has reached new lows brett
allie well done we'll continue to talk
about this thank you